Catherine Price: Hi, David.
David Biello: Hello.
CP: And hello, everyone.
DB: I think we need to start
with the question
that some of them may have seen
on their screen already:
what is fun?
CP: You might think
that we all know what fun is,
but I found it really interesting
in my research to realize
that the way we use fun
in our everyday speech,
which at least in English, is very casual,
we kind of toss around this word.
It's really different from the feeling
you get from people
if you ask them about a memory
from their own lives
in which they had the most fun.
And as part of the research
for my book, I did that.
I asked people from all around the world,
I see we have a ton of people
from all around the world,
even in this webinar.
So the answers I got
were very international.
And it was really interesting
because even though obviously people's
individual experiences were different,
there was this energy running through them
that was very much the same.
And when I read through these answers,
and I’ve got thousands of these by now,
I found myself smiling
but also almost tearing up a lot of times.
There was something really powerful
about what people were sharing with me
that went way beyond
this lighthearted pleasure sense
with which we often use the word.
So I ended up coming up
with a definition
based on these stories
people were sharing with me
and then running it by them to see
if it accurately described
what they had told me.
So I tried to validate it.
And it is that when we have these moments
of what I think of as “true” fun,
it's the confluence of three states.
And those are playfulness,
connection and flow.
And so if you think of a Venn diagram
with three circles in the center,
you have true fun, and then
playfulness, connection and flow.
And just to clarify, because people can
freak out in particular about playfulness,
adults really get uncomfortable
with playfulness.
It means just having
a lighthearted attitude.
You can just be lighthearted,
not care too much about the outcome
of what you're doing.
Let go of your perfectionism.
Connection refers to having
a special shared experience,
and I do think some people can have fun
on their own, as I say in my TED Talk.
But it was really interesting
because most of the stories people told me
involved other people.
And when I asked people, "What surprised
you about what you just told me?"
A number of people said something
along the lines of “I’m an introvert,
but everything I just told you
involved other people."
So in the majority of situations,
another person is involved.
And then flow is this psychological state
where we get so wrapped up
in what we're doing,
actively engaged in what we're doing
that we can lose track of time.
So an athlete playing a game
is the most quintessential example.
All three of those states
are great on their own
but I believe when you experience
all three at once,
that’s what I call true fun.
DB: So to the adult question of why
we lose playfulness, well,
I think some of it is because fun
can seem maybe frivolous
in a very serious world,
and the world is quite serious.
But why is it important to have fun?
CP: Thanks for asking
that question, David,
because that is a common misperception
people have about fun
is that it is frivolous or that, you know,
there are so many serious things
going on in the world,
how can we possibly think about fun?
So a couple of things I would say to that.
First of all, life is not zero-sum.
I don't see why you can't be someone
who cares about the serious
issues in the world
and also cares about fun.
And also,
a lot of what we do when we say
we're "caring about serious issues"
is really kind of meaningless
and just torturing ourselves.
If you read the same news article
that makes you upset six times in an hour,
you haven't actually helped anybody.
And the same thing if you've posted
a rant on social media
or gotten into an argument
or just worked yourself up
or essentially yelled
at someone on Twitter.
That didn’t actually help anybody.
And it's very draining.
So what I find about fun
is that when we actually have fun --
my point being here
is that fun can actually help us
work to solve some of those problems.
And the reason I say that
is that, first of all,
when you have enough fun yourself,
it actually fills up your own reserves,
it builds your resilience and your energy.
And that will give you the energy
to do something more productive
than just yell at people via your phones,
social media accounts.
But then also, if you actually
have fun with other people
and you've connected
with them as human beings,
so if we're able to have
fun with each other,
we can connect in a way
that then helps us work together
to actually solve some of those problems.
And then I would also say
fun isn't frivolous.
Even if the world was great
and there weren't any problems,
fun itself is not frivolous --
and I'm happy to go into more detail
if anyone wants more detail,
but is actually really important
not just for our mental health,
but also for our physical health
because of the way it reduces
our stress levels
and also provides us
with a sense of social connection.
DB: Yeah, fun is good for your health.
I think that's the important
thing to remember.
But as you pointed out,
we shouldn't get to wrapped up
maybe in anxiety
about whether we're having enough fun.
You also talk about something
called “fake” fun.
What's that?
CP: So fake fun is a term I came up with
to describe products and services
that are marketed to us as fun
but that aren't actually fun
in the sense that they don't actually
produce playfulness, connection or flow.
The biggest culprit here
is definitely social media and kind of --
or passive consumption
past the point of enjoyment.
So if you're watching your favorite
show for a couple episodes, great.
But if you're like, in that zone where
you're actually completely hypnotized
and seven hours have past
and you feel disgusting
about yourself and your life,
you've fallen into the trap of fake fun.
So I see it as there being actually
three categories.
You’ve got true fun,
the playful connected flow.
You’ve got fake fun,
which is essentially the junk food
of our leisure time.
It’s very appealing,
but it leaves us feeling
disgusting about ourselves.
There's a big middle category
of stuff that's truly enjoyable,
but that wouldn't necessarily
qualify as true fun
by the definition I've proposed.
And that would be things
like reading, you know,
or like taking a bath
or watching your favorite TV show
up to the point
where it's still enjoyable.
To me, those are all legitimate great
uses of your leisure time,
even if they're not fun
because you know you actually enjoy them.
And the reason I think it's important
to think so intellectually about fun
is that it helps us become
much more intentional
about how we use our leisure time.
So if you're able to identify sources
of fake fun in your life,
it's actually really easy
to eliminate those
once you've kind of cognitively recognized
that you know it's a waste of time.
And if you're like, "Oh yeah,
this is actually enjoyable,"
go for it.
And then if it's likely
to generate true fun,
I would suggest putting it
on the top of your priority list
because it's such
a wonderfully nourishing state.
DB: TED Member Don
and Stephania are, you know,
feel slightly overwhelmed by their lives
and have trouble even thinking
of what fun feels like.
If you've forgotten what fun feels like,
how do you find it again?
CP: One of the things
I recommend people do to start
is to think back on a moment
of true fun from your own life,
a moment that you describe as "so fun."
That was the term I came up with
when I was asking people this question.
Don't worry, it can actually take
a little bit of time
to tune in to those experiences,
but I can assure you we've all had them.
They don't need to be dramatic.
This is another misconception
we have about fun,
that it only can happen in exotic locales
or when you're somehow
outside of your "normal life"
or that it costs a lot of money.
None of that is true.
If you define it as playful
connected flow,
you'll start to recognize that you can
have even tiny moments of fun
all the time.
And the reason you want to call to mind
one of these experiences
is that, as you begin to think
of more of them,
so I encourage you to try
to think of more than one,
and it will become easier
as you start thinking of them,
to call out some themes
and see are there any particular
people who are often involved?
Are there any activities
that are involved?
Are there any settings
that seem conducive to fun?
Because if you’ve seen my TED Talk,
you know that I believe that fun
is a feeling and it’s not an activity.
By which I mean that, I think
too often we start to think,
like, if I asked you guys what's fun,
just at the beginning
of this conversation,
you might start to give me a list
of activities that you enjoy.
Cooking's fun or reading or whatever,
but the activity itself is not fun.
It's the feeling of fun.
Like, you can love dinner parties
and have the exact same group
of people over for dinner
and eat the exact same thing.
And one night it's going to be really fun
and one night it's not.
So it's the feeling that results.
So the point of calling out these
settings and these people and activities
that are often associated with fun for you
is not to guarantee that you
can have fun if you're with them,
but to set the scene for it
to make it more likely
that fun will occur in result.
I think about it like romance,
like you can set the scene for it,
but if you try too hard,
it's going to run away, right?
So we’re trying to light candles for fun.
But I call the settings and the people
and the activities our fun magnets,
and each of us has a collection
that is unique to us, you know.
My husband's fun magnets
are not necessarily the same as mine.
We have some that we share,
some that are different.
And the point is just to become more
cognizant of what those things are
so again, you can become more intentional
about how you choose
to spend your leisure time.
I also created a whole acronym in the book
and a framework that's called SPARK,
which I'm happy to go through,
but I'll just end up talking straight
for half an hour if I go down that route.
But I'd start with that,
try to identify past memories of fun,
look for themes and then prioritize
those people and activities and settings.
DB: Well, let's talk
about SPARK a little bit,
because in looking through the chat,
I mean, that's why we ask
for the moments of delight.
It's a moment for people to reflect
and think about something
that was probably pretty fun.
If it delighted you,
it was probably pretty fun.
So tell us a little bit more
about the importance of noticing
and this whole SPARK method.
CP: So the first step in SPARK, the S,
actually stands for "make space"
because we do need
to clear out some space for fun.
If you're feeling constantly overwhelmed,
you're probably going to feel like
you can't even begin this process.
What I recommend that people start with
in terms of clearing space
is to begin with the biggest
source of distraction
for most of us these days,
which is our phones
and our digital devices.
Before the pandemic,
the average person in America was spending
upwards of four hours a day
just on their phones.
So not their tablets, not their computers,
not their TVs, just their phones,
which is a quarter of your waking life,
and it adds up to 60 full days a year.
When you think about it that way, sure,
some of that time is useful and productive
and perhaps essential,
but there's also a lot of it that's just
a kind of, frittering away of time,
the fake fun that we're talking about.
And if you're able to create better
boundaries with your devices
and more of what I call
screen-life balance,
you're going to end up with more free time
that you then can devote
towards pursuing fun.
So another way to create space
is actually to think
about your commitments
and see which ones you could say no to.
Like, for example, I used to volunteer
in my daughter's preschool board
and then at some point I'm like,
the school's fine, I'm not adding to it,
and I'm not enjoying
the meetings and so I quit
and it cleared up a lot of space.
Also, giving yourself a permission slip
is huge in terms of making space.
A lot of people think
that they don't deserve fun,
that there are too many other priorities,
they're taking care of other people,
their needs are at the bottom of the list.
I've actually had people say
that they have written out
an actual permission slip for themselves
and signed it.
So if that's your deal, do it.
I think it's actually really important
whether it's a literal permission slip
or a mental one.
Then the P is to pursue passions
and hobbies and interests.
The more interests you have and the more
skills and knowledge you have,
the more interesting your life
will be, first of all,
but also the more portals into playful
connected flow you'll find.
And the thing that sparked
that idea for me
was the book "Flow"
by Mihaly Csikszentmihalyi
who was the psychologist
who coined the term flow.
And in his book he made this comment
that really stood out to me,
which was that to someone
who doesn't play chess,
a chess board is just a board
with some carved figurines.
Honestly, that's what it still is to me.
But if you know how to play chess,
if you put in the work
to learn to play chess,
it becomes a portal into flow.
And I would argue, into fun.
But the idea is just get out there,
try something new, do something new,
get up off your couch, you know.
It might take a bit to get over
your inertia at first, but it is worth it.
So that's the P, is to pursue passions.
The A of spark is for attract fun
because you probably have noticed
there are certain people in your life
who just seem to have more fun than you
and you might not know why --
you have fun, too, David.
This guy, just look at him
having lots of fun.
But when I asked people in my research,
I straight up asked them,
“Describe someone in your life
whom you consider a ‘fun person,’
and then tell me like,
what about them makes them fun?"
And even I thought that I’d get a lot
of really stereotypical responses:
"they're extroverts"
or "they're the lives of the party"
or "they're the class clowns."
There were some of those.
But it was so interesting
because a lot of people said things like,
“They make everyone feel
very comfortable in their presence.”
Or “They laugh very easily
at other people’s jokes or stories.”
Or “They go along with things,
they go with the flow.”
And it really stood out to me
because the traits they were describing
were not necessarily associated
with extroversion.
So you can be an introvert
and make someone feel comfortable.
I think in some cases introverts
are better at tuning into that.
And also a lot of them were trainable.
You can get better at those skills.
So I got really interested in the idea
of how do we become people
who attract more fun,
and I think what I just described
are three ways to do so.
Another is to switch yourself
into what I think of as a fun mindset,
which is a fun-oriented twist
on Carol Dweck's growth mindset.
And the idea there
is that our default mode,
our brain's default mode,
is naturally going to be to focus
on things that cause us anxiety and fear
for the simple reason that that's
evolutionarily how we avoid threats.
You want to be scanning
the horizon for threats,
otherwise you could get killed
or eaten or something.
So it actually takes work to switch
yourself to focus on the positive.
And I think that the more you do so,
the more likely you are to notice
the moments of playful connected flow
and to create more opportunities for it.
So if you can start to begin
to deliberately pay more attention
to the delight in the world,
instead of going with the natural tendency
to focus on sources of anxiety and fear,
it really will get you into a mindset
that's much more conducive.
The R in SPARK may be my favorite.
It is for rebel.
DB: Yes! Yes!
CP: (Laughs)
Not like "get yourself in jail"
rebellion, to clarify.
But when I was reading
through people's anecdotes,
there was this repeated theme of playful
deviance is what I'll call it,
of breaking the rules,
just like, a little bit, you know.
I mean skinny dipping
would be an example of that.
But even someone who said that they had
snuck into a pool, you know,
at night, I think fully clothed,
with like, a laundry basket
and some pool noodles.
I don’t know, and like,
they’d had a great time.
Or really anything,
like if you normally listen
to educational podcasts,
maybe you can drive around in your car
and turn off the podcast and the news
and just like blast the song you loved
when you were 17 and sing along.
You know, or just take
a little break from your workday
to do something that will bring you
a sense of delight.
So rebellion.
And if you can't think
of a way to do that,
I think it's also kind of fun to think
about ways to do something delightful
for somebody else,
a way to do something
that's going to surprise them.
So maybe this is a little bit separate,
but I find that that can be a way
if you're still thinking,
I can't think of something
to do in my own life,
do something to delight someone else.
And then lastly,
the K of SPARK is keep at it,
which basically means that fun
is much like exercise,
like, you're not going to do it once
and then that's it, you're done.
You actually have to keep prioritizing it
because life is going to keep throwing
like, not fun things your way.
And unless you're working
to keep that as a priority,
it's not going to be a priority.
And the way that I personally think
about approaching that
is in terms of what I call microdoses
and then booster shots.
So if you know that there's
something small,
a little microdose that you could work
into your schedule regularly
that you enjoy, that might lead
to playful connected flow,
like a regular coffee date
or a walk with a friend
who you've realized
is a fun magnet for you.
Or in my case, like,
my weekly guitar class
is definitely regular microdoses.
Build that into your schedule,
carve out the time for it.
And then a booster shot would be
something that takes more time,
more energy, maybe more money.
Although again, fun doesn't
necessarily require money.
But, you know, if you know
that every time you get together
with this particular group of friends,
it's just outrageously fun,
then, like, actually go
to the work of organizing
and figuring out how to get
childcare and whatever
so you can spend time with them.
And I think that if you can
sprinkle these microdoses
and booster shots
into your life regularly,
you will build the framework
for a life that is conducive to fun.
DB: So one of the things
that I found fun in your book
is that you called for a fun audit.
CP: You thought that sounded fun, David,
I think that sounds incredibly unfun.
DB: Well, I'm saying it sounds
like an oxymoron, right?
But actually,
a fun audit can be a good thing to do
if you're feeling stuck.
So tell us about a fun audit.
CP: The fun audit involves looking,
reviewing your own life and just
noticing how much fun you are
or are not having,
scanning through your leisure activities
and identifying those sources
of fake fun that we're talking about
so that you can begin to reduce
or eliminate them.
And then very importantly,
figuring out some activities
or something to do
to replace the time that you were spending
on the time-sucking fake fun.
DB: But, you know,
it is a struggle for some folks.
And Kat wants to know how we can create
fun while grappling with things
like climate change or nuclear war
or all the other, you know,
frankly, existential threats
that are out there in the world.
CP: I think it's really important.
I think a lot of people feel that way
and that we do get consumed.
And the media landscape is designed
to make us feel that way.
That's another thing to acknowledge,
is that not only are our brains
naturally primed to notice those things,
but you know, there's an expression
in journalism: if it bleeds, it leads.
Like, you never open up
your favorite newspaper
and see an article about how
there's a real explosion in puppies,
like, that doesn't happen.
So I think also being more judicious
about what you allow into your brain
because, I mean, any time
you pick up your phone,
I think of it as a Pandora's
box of emotions.
It's going to result in an emotion.
What emotion is that going to be,
and do you want that in your brain?
If you check the news,
it’s going to have an impact
on your mental state.
If you check your email,
if you check social media.
I'm not saying I know what that reaction
is going to be for you,
but there is going to be one.
So as an example,
I used to have the news app on my phone,
and I would find myself reading
the same articles again and again,
hoping something would have changed,
which it didn't.
Then I realized, I'm not going
to have the news app on my phone.
Think about notifications
as interruptions
because that's really what they're doing.
And then I would suggest asking yourself
what you want to be interrupted for.
Because notifications are there
for the benefit of the people
making the app
that sent you the notification,
it's not for you.
And I think that many of us
feel very, very trapped
in this feeling that the world
is dark and horrible
and that we're powerless.
And that's a horrible place to be.
And I think it takes a lot of work
to bring yourself out of that.
But it's worth it.
And it actually is good for trying
to address some of those things.
DB: I think fun is probably best shared,
as you noted earlier.
Any tips on how to share fun
with the folks in our lives?
I think Jim wanted to know that.
CP: Well, I think picking
the right people is important.
There’s certain people that really
are not conducive to fun,
and hopefully you can help
them to change, right?
But as a first step,
if you have the choice
between hanging out with someone
who consistently makes you
feel comfortable
and you enjoyed being in the presence of
and generates fun,
versus someone who's a wet blanket,
pick that one, right?
Again, I talked about doing
things together.
I think that things
like cooking a meal together
or trying something new together
or seeing if your friends want to go
to a class together or, you know,
all those things are very conducive
to opening people up
in a way that helps people have fun.
I think also trying to find people
who are already having fun
and joining that group.
DB: I want to thank
all the members for coming.
I also want to apologize for not getting
to all of your questions,
but the time just kind of flew by
because, you know, we were having fun.
So thank you.
Thank you very much
for joining us today,
and go have some fun.
CP: Thanks, David, you too.
[Want to support TED?]
[Become a TED Member!]
[Learn more at ted.com/membership]